今天这节课非常重要，可以学的东西非常多。其实这个幸福终点站呢，我在几年前应该是讲过一次，但是为什么再拿出来讲呢？有几个原因。
第一个呢，我们拉片的话绕不过。
这个老汤哥啊汤们。
汤姆汉克斯以及斯皮尔伯格。
所以说这个。
斯皮尔伯格和汤姆帕克斯这对组合排出的这种。
包括这个拯救大病瑞安和这个幸福终点站啊是必须要看的。
嗯，演技也好，还是导演技法也好，这两个人都是巅峰巅峰级别的存在。第二个原因呢是其实这个斯皮尔伯格包括这个。
这个。
他们汉克斯吧。
呃，这两个人在美国啊都属于。
非常传统价值观的人。
这两个人你可以理解他们经常拍一些美国政治正确的片子，而且。
美国的文艺界啊。
主流其实是。
那个民主派啊。
但是呢。
汉斯先生啊。
他经常是代表共和的价值。
共和价值观啊。
嗯，你可以理解是传统的。
嗯。
美式家族。
呃，再加上这部片子，有大量的东西方隐喻。
是值得我们去看一看的啊。
我们只从故事的角度，从艺术的角度。
这是第二个原因，就是这个片子啊，还有一些意义上的拔高啊，事业上的拔高。这个是我们有很多年轻的创作者啊在写东西的时候啊是喜欢搞点比喻啊，是喜欢搞点红涂呐喊。正好从这部片子学一学。第三呢这部片子还有凯瑟琳泽塔情思啊。
咱们得看一看年轻时候的对吧？盛世美颜啊，这个凯瑟林泽拉说啊，这个可以说是曾经一度也是世界前三一样的存在啊。然后第四个原因啊也很重要。这部片子是真人真事改编，这几年呢真人真事改编这个东西吧。
也是在咱们国家的这个主流商业片里面也是很受欢迎。咱们借由这部片子看一下一部真人真事改编的电影，如何变得商业化，如何变得好看，以及改编的尺度怎么去拿捏？好吧，我们怀着这几点啊诉求来看这部片子。我认为这部片子啊。
确实写的太好啊也太好，把一个真人真事方寸之间的一个故事拿捏的如此之好啊，配得上他在世界影史上的地位。学过嗯，大师就是大师我一直非常非常喜欢啊，没什么好讨论？这个。
神一样的存在的这个大导演大级片员啊来。
开始。
先看信息班，这部片子由于名场面非常多啊，所以说我们在看信息班的同时，就直接把一些名场面咱们一起看一下。如果耽误点时间，大家就谅解一下好不好？你如果再认真一点，提前拉一拉这个片子的结构和信息节拍是更好的。如果没有按照我说的去记。
记完之后自己去补好不好？再去看一遍也是好的，好吗？我们每一部电影的目标就是看完看完一次啊就学就学会写了，就这种类型遇到就不慌了啊，最好是这样来。
这部电影信息包信息节拍第一部分。7，我们说这个电影啊呃四幕式也是比较明确的啊，每一幕的主题也比较明确啊。第一幕我们记一下关键词叫被困。
你可以理解就是激利事件嘛，对吧？被困了嘛，激利事件是第一幕，第一第一幕第一拍第一分钟。
先交代的是机场大环境啊，一个忙碌的大环境，先交代环境。因为未来这是主角的主场景嘛，先交代环境，然后反派先登场。这部戏的第一集第一场反派就先登场了，而且还展示了反派的技能，对吧？这个是稍微有点小小的反常规操作啊，展现反派的技能。
火眼金睛的技能，让大家感觉以为他是主角呢，是吧？这是大大导演啊的跳这个俏皮，因为他有汤姆汉克斯，对吧？其实是稳稳的，有这样级别的男主角就很稳的，他先擦一擦稳得住是吧？
但是第一场呢嗯有小小的辱华嫌疑啊，这个我们嗯暂时不去讨论，因为他火眼金睛抓的偷渡客是华人啊，想想。
投渡到美国去。好，第二拍第二分钟，我们的男主登场。
男主登场呢上来就被扣留了，被困。然后呢轻微的展示一下他的人设，就是这个人呢适应能力很强啊，嗯用的是什么一个很俏皮的事儿展现他适应能力很强呢？他在那被被困了，在那刮胡子，记得那场戏吧，小小的一个人设啊。
小环境也是挺能适应的，暗示他后面要在这里小环境这个被被困住了啊。好，我们接着往下说啊，明场面很多，我们不能耽误时间。第三拍来到第三分钟，第三拍来到第三分钟，被审他被拉到审讯室啊嗯把这个把这个基地事件彻底讲清楚了，就是他的国家灭亡了啊，他现在无处可去。
暂时没有国家，所以困在了这里，成为了一个不被接受的人啊，不被接受的人。来到第四盘第八分钟介绍男主可以活动的范围，实际上就是再次精确一下主角的环境啊。我们说第一第第一坨戏一般是交代主角环境的，交代了大环境了，现在交代小环境啊，可以活动的这个范围就是。
国际中转区男主呢也从新闻中得知了自己的处境，很长的一场戏啊，镜头也很复杂。呃，学导演的同学可以看一下第四拍啊，介绍主角活动的可以活动的环境，以及他这从新闻中得知自己的处境，这是一场很长的戏，镜头非常复杂。
长镜头啊这个。
呃，学导演的同学可以着重去看一下这场戏啊，我就我是编剧老师，我就不展示了。
第五拍14分钟。
嗯，开始在这个小环境里生存，嗯，开场嗯先做个救猫咪，然后救猫咪就成了吗？
看过的同学回忆一下来。
开始在这扎下根，就开始做旧猫咪。
是啥旧猫咪自己回忆一下啊，而且因为旧猫咪呢还把食品券给弄丢了，对吧？
食品件给弄丢了。
然后这个。
食食品券被谁拿走了？食品券被谁打走了？
嗯，这个印度人啊，我们知道啊在美国。
机场打工的人啊呃一半以上是印度人啊，这也是一种你可以理解也是一种算刻板偏见嘛，不算吧，就是在在机场打扫卫生的搬行李的基本上都是印度人啊，算是吧，但可能也是。
那可能也是一定程度上的一些一些概率啊，来来到第五拍啊，第六拍第16分钟，他找找到了自己的家啊，呃一个废弃的67号登机口啊，是在建的67号登机口，反正废荒废吧啊，然后自己动手打造了一个暂时家，暂时的家。
同时呢也第一次拿出了一个罐子啊，就是他的伏笔。
一个罐子啊，那是一个整个片子的一个点睛的一个道具。他第一次拿出来了。
我们说啊行为到现在啊整个剧本行为到现在都是在交代主角的环境和困境啊，环境和困境一定记住啊。你看这都是大师都是这么玩的，对吧？老师在课上给你们这么讲，你体会的不那么深的话，看一看大师的作品啊，就哎就就就就就知道怎么回事了。
然后来到第七拍第19分钟。
反一反一我们说在第一场其实已经登过场了啊，在这里嗯把他的。
动力做出来，它的压力是什么？
是快要升职了，这段时间不能出错。记不记得反一。我们说反一要做的事情有理由可以增强反一的可怕性。其实严格说这个反一并不是一个绝对意义的坏人，这个大家理解啊，但是由于他快要升职了。
暗示他会箭走偏逢，他会非常狠。
好吧，这是一种很常见的处理手法。这个你们要记笔记要学你的反医，你你要写反译的时候想一想你的反医做这些坏事有没有合理性。如果他有个合理性，其实他会更可怕，而且还会往回捞一下他的人设。因为并不是所有人都是那种十恶不赦的大坏蛋，就是愿意折腾别人，就是愿意欺负别人。
并不是。
因为他要升职了。
然后他发现这个男主还没有走。
所以呢。
嗯，相当于是男主遇到了困境。在第一幕啊，男主遇到了困境是没有护照了，走不了。然后呢，他的。
这个目标是只能待在这儿。但是呢实际上反派是觉得他没有必要待在这儿，你可以理解这是召唤与拒绝召唤啊。激励事件之后有召唤与拒绝召唤。因为激励事件之后，我们说进入第二幕，我们主角的第一个选择是什么？
这个片子里面有曾经无数次出现这个词。
进入第二幕，我们的主角的目标是什么？
在这个片子里面出现频率最高的一个词儿。
这个故事进入第二幕幕之后。
wait等待啊等待这部片子讲的就是wait。
好吧。
所以你可以理解，激励事件是他的国家没有了，他没有护照了。然后呢，它产生的第一个目标就是wait原地wait原地等待啊。我们的反医其实是想勾引他，别在这等。所以你可以理解这是召唤与拒绝召唤啊，仍然在第一幕第七拍就是呢他反医发现男主还没走。
第八拍。
2一场。
我们的男主坚持不断的申请，但是呢不断的被拒绝。然后我们的反派就更加惊奇，竟然有人这么死心眼，就在这等，对吧？这依然是召唤与拒绝召唤。第九拍来到第24分钟，我们反派。
诱惑男主逃跑，向社局抓他，对吧？诱惑他，别胃疼。
但是男主没有上当，坚持wait。
把自己的目标用自己的嘴说了出来，I wait第一幕结束，看一下这场戏，24分钟。
我们说这个这场电影这部电影是标准的120分钟，非常嗯非常整啊，2小时。所以它的分布基本上是25、35、35、25。
2535、35、25。我给课上讲过这个比例，大家记不记得？
25、35、35、25。所以第一幕到24分钟啊，I wait.
the airport police port authority。
第一幕结束，把目标明确出来。我们说第一目就是为了明确第一个目标，记不记得？第一目就是为为了明确第一个目标，i wait。
所以进入第二幕，第二幕目的主题是什么？wait等待。
第二幕的主题就是wait等待。
第十拍28分钟，好好学啊，这部电影真的是这个剧本真的写的好。进入第二幕1wait段啊，第十拍28分钟wait段女伙伴提前登场，哪一个伙伴爱情啊，第一个伙伴爱情登场。当然那个印度老头提前也出过场了，但是产生交情必然是第二幕。
这个是非常规整的，你们自己拉的时候看到没有啊？爱情和所有的伙伴的建立伙伴关系在都在第二幕的中前期特别的特别的漂亮啊，放的位置特别的好。
女主东察两个人相遇。
然后呢，这个女主有一个呃一看就是一个那个那个金主爸爸啊，他们叫。
suger daddy是吧？糖爸爸啊，这里是先把爱情扔出来。第1一拍来到29分钟，伙伴群登场。伙伴群登场呢用的也是比较特别的一个手法，就是伙伴伙伴群在讨论这个奇怪的东欧人啊，奇怪的东方人，在讨论这个男主，用讨论的形式展现这个男主的。
穿插展现这个男主行为。来到第十二趴。
30分钟，男主很饿啊，因为他要wait嘛，wait.
wa他要解决的第一个问题啊。
wa他要解决的第一个问题是挣钱的问题。他发现了手推车挣钱大法进入游戏时光啊。我们说在这部在这个电影里，其实上路之后，游戏时光嗯和伙伴登场。嗯，一般来说，游戏时光往前放一放啊。但是呢这次这部戏先让女主和伙伴轻微的登场。
没有跟主角建立关系，然后呃登场完了之后再给他游戏时光啊，伙食变好了，包括有那个钱打脸的名场面，记不记得看一眼吧，好吧，30分钟左右，我们说游戏时光啊都是伴随着比较轻快的BGM。
叫快捷的剪辑。我们说像这种片子啊，其实是非常写实的，但是里面穿插一点这种小小的幽默元素啊，无伤大雅，而且挺好玩的。钱打脸这个名场面啊，游戏时光。我们说游这是标准的游戏时光，挣钱钱打脸开心，对不对？
十三班来到32分钟。
被新闻刺激了啊，开始学英语。
英文突飞猛进，这场戏其实也写的非常有意思啊，因为他能买到不同语种的书同一本书，然后在那对照着学英文，英文突飞猛进啊，因为咱们这个都是字母语系，可能学的比较快吧。
来到第1四拍34分钟。
再一次去海关妹妹那里申请签证啊，博得美儿一笑。哎，那个海关妹妹是谁呀？
那个疫勤工作的那个妹妹是谁啊？就是盖章的那个妹妹。
是阿凡达的女主啊，同学们。
他还演过那个银河护卫队是吧？
接着往下说啊。
啊，在这里是为什么呢？是因为他逗的这个美女一笑引起了伙伴的注意啊，第15拍35分钟，反派发力啊，斩断了男主的赚钱之路，男主又一次挨饿。
第十六拍。
刚刚开始挨饿啊，呃遇到了女主擦肩而过。
再次把这个。
女主又往外扔了一下啊，爱情往外扔了一下，然后其他的伙伴也往外扔了一下。我们说第二幕啊就是折腾伙伴和爱情这点事儿呗，因为他自己的这个目标不太主动，同学们可以理解一下啊。
你们自己琢磨一下。
在第二幕啊，主角的目标其实不太主动，因为是wait嘛，是吧？不太主动，而且不太明确，有点模糊的。所以呢这个爱情和爱情和伙伴就得多折腾折腾，这也是没有办法的啊，没有办法。
然后第1七拍来到37分钟，这个南美小哥啊，我们说这个南美小哥提出了实物换情报的一个呃交易模型，两个人达成了协议。因为一个缺吃的，一个缺情报嘛。
然后十八拍来到39分钟啊，开始执行泡妞任务。
好几个回合啊。
嗯，就是帮着这个南美小哥去不断的去套取这个呃这个这个。
美女的这个。
情报。
呃，同学们想一想啊，但实际上这里的话，主线目标就放缓了。
实际上没有办法啊，同学们可以，我们说这肯定是一个缺陷。
我们得承认啊，在这里花这么多的回合数去泡伙伴的妞，去帮伙伴泡妞，主线任务肯定是往下走。
这个嗯大师斯皮尔伯格就是大师，但是这个问题我们也得指出来，因为解决不了。
就好像我们去说那个嗯。
奔驰大G油耗高一样，明白你们明白我在说什么吗？就奔驰大G油耗高可不可以说可以说能解决吗？解决不了啊，解决不了。因为它的为了契合契合主题啊，它的第二幕这个确实是确实不主动啊，来来到接着往下说来到第1九拍。
43分钟，那个呼击响起来了啊，希望来了反派攻击第二招啊。你看啊那个创作者也知道前面这一拍玩多了，导致主线目标放缓，所以赶紧给个危机啊，反派赶紧因为能够带来因为主角是被动的。
等待嘛，那能够带来攻击性的就是这个反派了啊，赶紧让反派用第二招。
反派的第二招是什么呢？诱惑他签那个政治避难。
啊，承认害怕自己的国家或者自己的国家对自己不友善啊，就政治避难。同学们了解政治就是这个这种条款吗？就是害怕自己的国家认为自己在自己的国家不安全，然后做一个申请就可以待在美国典型的案例。
凤姐凤姐就是通过这种形式。
实现了那边的居住啊。
然后呢，但是我们的男主不愿意承认啊不愿意承认嗯自己害怕自己的国家，害怕自己的这个这个这个祖国啊，他不愿意承认。你看这我我讲过啊，这部片子有非常强烈的政治隐喻。
他的国家都打仗了，是吧？产生了暴动。
甚至死了很多人，但是他绝不能承认自己害怕祖国啊。
不害怕，看一下这个名场面吧啊，这场戏还是。
非常有代表性的啊，因为确实是。
这是一个标准的呃东西方思维的一个罪状啊，为什么会没有对错啊？同学们没有对错？呃，为什么呃美国会有这种思维啊？因为美美国这个国家的建立就是一群背井离乡的人去选择了一个他们认为更好的地方，建造了一个他们认为更好的国家嘛。
所以他们本身就是一群呃离开过家乡的人，但是在东方啊，特别是在世界其他的地方，特别是东方啊。嗯呃大部分人还是有很深的。
故土情节啊，包括你看咱们过年对吧？冲破一切阻碍，也要回老家去过，也不知道为什么这个。
确实啊这个是个文化对撞。在这个片子里面嗯这样的东西方文化对撞，我们看完片子可以讨论啊，可以讨论。嗯，大家不用去讨论政治，好吧，我们这节课不讨论政治，好不好？同学们，咱们嗯先嗯我们只讨论这个片子所展现出来的一些隐喻。
比喻这些对撞啊这些可以值得我们学习的地方，我们不讨论政治，好不好？
来回到故事第20盘47分钟。
男主再次遇到女主啊，两人的距离似乎要拉近了，但是又破裂了啊。嗯因为我们的男主受困于此，所以女主失望的离开了。
然后但是呢促使我们男主产生了一个新的目标啊。
也就是第。
21盘52分钟，我们的男主有一个新的目标啊，他想请女主吃饭，但是需要40美元。第22拍来到第53分钟，他开始找工作啊，处出被剧。在这里呢找工作又用了一个蒙太奇啊，是比较典型的三番四斗。
记不记得找工作的那个蒙太奇啊，那是一个标准的美式结构啊。我在课上也给大家讲过，同学们呃要写小段子的时候，或或者要写一些比较轻快的镜头的时候，是可以这样的啊，就是三番四柳什么意思啊？就是连续三次冲击目标，一次比一次接近。然后呢？
第四次终于看起来要成功了，但是呢也失败了，好不好？我们来看一下这个三番四楼好吧，因为这种情况在日常生活中日常写作当中经常要用到，我希望同学们都学会，好不好？
34斗啊，找工作。
大家看啊，123翻啊。
先确定一下钱，然后准备去找工作。你看啊一次比一次接近啊，因为一次一次跟他聊的东西多，就看起来一次比一次接近目标，明白吗？他其实前面是四分啊，所以是个四分五斗。
1234啊前面有4次尝试，实际上一般来说用三次就够了。他用了4次尝试。然后第五次来到这个discovery啊，discovery应该是卖户外用品的，对吧？卖卖卖卖卖户外用品的，然后然后这个看起来要成了，因为留电话了嘛，接近成功啊。
最后这一楼一抖全都点到为止啊，全都点到为止啊，几次尝试。然后有一次终于把节奏放缓下来，眼看就要成功了，他解决了所有的问题，对吧？也也有电话留给人家了，但是呢等等等，最后抖电话打过来是错的啊，是还是失败了，还是不用他。
而且还让他赶紧走，而且他还憋着尿，差点还进了女厕所。
这个这种小结构啊在日常创作中经常要用到，好不好？经常要用到啊。
而且这种情况也一般都是配着这个笔g。
有同学说目的是什么？
这场戏不是废戏，是在主线目标上，他需要钱去约那个女人。
这是他是在主线目标上了，这场可不是废戏，这俩戏在主线目标上，对不对？挣钱呀。
好吧。
来到第23排。
55分钟是别说经典吐槽了，这种事儿，这些这个事儿传来传去，我要开始得罪人了，我就给随便举个例子而已啊。
第那个23排55分钟啊，然后回来之后很郁闷，半夜刷墙姐妹儿啊却意外得到了好工作。其实你可以理解啊，半夜回来刷墙姐妹儿跟前面那是一坨戏。
同学们回忆一下，记不记得。
我给你们讲过。
我给你们讲三0四0的时候，我给你举个例子，我说一个小孩问妈妈要钱。
第一次想一个理由，第二次想一个理由，第三次想一个理由全都越来越接近目标。
对吧第一次说自己想想买买玩具，第二次想买吃的，第三次想买学习用品就逐渐快要接近目标了，结果都被妈妈一个巴掌打回来，你还要钱，这就三番。然后四斗是什么呢？他最后破罐破摔说玩天玩那个我其实那个我我坦白了，我想泡妞，对吧？
我我想给我们班班花买礼物，哎，这个看起来不会成的事儿，反而成了。
对吧然后最后再翻，其实是帮他爸要的，明白吗？
他这个呢失败了以后回来。
闲着没事，刷个墙，竟然把工作得到了。所以说回来刷墙这件事情理论上跟三翻四手是一起的。来来到第24盘58分钟和伙伴们成为好朋友啊啊赢得了大家的信任。因为伙伴在这场在第二幕里面虽然一直出现，一直跟他纠缠，但是呢。
呃，其实只有那个南美小哥接受了他啊，这个印度大叔一直没接受他，所以这场其实是完成了印度大叔对他的信任。另外也再次提到了那个罐子啊，因为那个重要的道具罐子也再次提了一下。
来到第25拍。
60分钟，再次遇到女主，两个人也来电了啊，而且两个人之这个之间有一个共同的秘密语言，就是关于拿破仑的故事啊，就是拿破仑和他爱人的爱情故事，是两个人的一个引经据典啊。
然后两个人相约了午餐。
但是呢这个女主心有所属，这个女主有一个呃金主爸爸啊，故事来到第三部。
我们说第二幕是等待。
等待是什么意思啊？
等待是原地不动啊原地不动。那第三步开始。
男主要开始改变。
记一下关键词啊，第一幕的关键词是被困，你可以理解就是激励事件是开端嘛，就是这件事情的开端，它被困了激励事件。
第二目的关键词是他第一阶段的目标。
等待。
第二幕就是他的第一个目标等待。
进入第三幕，他开始实现第二节，开始开始不等待了，做第二件事情跟等待相反的是什么呢？改变。
记一下啊，第三幕关键词是改变，也就是故事终点以后，来到第26拍64分钟，迫使他改变了，当然还是外力啊。这个坏蛋气急败坏，看他很不顺眼把他抓了起来。第27拍来了66分钟？为什么其实是机场迎来了上级市察啊，关乎这个反派的升迁。
反派呢大显身手，开始搞的是很好的啊，那个那个发现有人藏毒啊。
大前身手，然后来到第28拍67分钟。
呃，那个反派这边出事了，我们说在这个故事里面，我们的主角确实不够被动啊，我们客观承认在这个故事里面，主角是不够主动的，他是比较被动的啊。我们承认出事了啊。
有一个这个呃人发狂了啊，这个人是个某某斯坦人，你可以理解也是东方啊东方东欧小国东方小国。然后呢需要我们的男主进行翻译。因为这个斯拉夫语系啊，这个这个呃我们的男主是能翻译的，可能不是一个国家，但是能翻译啊，都是一个语系的。
然后这场戏就非常代表性的体现了男主开始干什么了。
我刚才说这一场的关键词是什么？
这一场的关键词是什么啊？上一场的关键词词是等待，等待包含很多啊，坚守包含包含这个这个原则，对吧？
在这场戏里面，我们的男主主动。
做出了改变。
代表呃世世件是什么撒谎。
撒谎对吧？他在第他在故事的第二幕，自己被困在机场，为了自己的生存都没有撒谎过。
为了自己的生存，为了爱情泡妞，他都不愿意撒谎。但是故事进入第三幕。
他开始改变了，他撒谎了。
你可以理解这是男主的成长。同时呢反派的升值也被破坏了啊，暂时被破坏啊，暂时被破坏。我说这场戏啊他做出了改变。但是呢我一直强调啊，在这个故事里面，这个反派啊，所谓的这个反派啊，人家并没有做到把他呃斯皮尔伯格并没有把他做到十恶不赦，是为什么啊？
因为这个反派代表的是美利国，他很严苛坚守原则。但是呢嗯一旦回回归这个呃这个规矩以内，他也没有办法啊。来到第29拍，74分钟，74分钟啊，29拍男主的英雄事迹广泛被传送。
外号，而且有了自己的外号啊呃成为了the goat。
我们说the goat是双关的啊，在这场戏里面，它呃the goat在英文里面是双关的，大家知道吧？greates of all time，对吧？时尚最佳，你可以理解goat那个michael jordan不是被称为the goat嘛，对吧？在NB在NBA里称为the goat，对吧？呃， greatestest of all time.
啊，史上最佳你可以理解啊，史上最佳的意思。
the goat啊，所以说这是一个双冠，他呢成为了机场的明星啊，他的外号就是the goat。
嗯，还是非常美国文化的一个东西啊，来到30拍76分钟啊，男主又去找反派商量。
呃，想走，但是反派呢想知道罐子的秘密，嗯，两个人谈崩了啊，在这里这场戏非常明显啊，就是这个反派其实并没有呃十恶不赦。在这场戏里面非常明确的展现了这两个人是两生花。我曾经讲过啊，主角和反派就是困在。
主角哎，我我主角被困在这个机场等待着。
呃，那个回家。
反卖呢？
反派是不是也困在这个机场，他在机场工作了17年，他梦寐以求的就是当个处长升官。
他也被困在这个机场，明白吗？这场戏可以看一下，我们课上讲过主角和反派，最好就是一颗枝头上开出的不同的两朵花。啊，在这部电影里面展现的淋漓尽致啊，淋漓尽致，非常的规整啊。
诗的作品就是不一样，把礼物又拿走了，生气了啊。
所以像像这种故事里面的反派实际上还是有点可爱的啊。那其实这个电电影就非常难啊呃，就从行为上就非常难。首先主角不够主动。第二呢反派不够坏，然后想还要把这个把这个故事写的有趣，就就很累啊来。
来到第31盘78分钟，伙伴们啊帮着男主泡妞，因为还有三周，女主就回来了，他们要最后冲刺做各种准备，包括呃这个这个钱上，包括这个形象上要买西服啊，什么乱七八糟的啊，包括要侦查这个女主回来的时间要制造偶遇。第32盘第81分钟。
我们说他开始主动出击了，我们说这其实都是改变啊。我讲过第三幕主要讲改变，你看他现在也开始违反原则，呃，获取情报呃，造假、制造偶遇去泡妞，明白吗？全是各种改变啊，各种改变。
第32拍81分钟。
呃，等待女主回来的这个这个设局，等待女主回来之前垫了一个小小节拍啊，我们单独把它拎出来。就是印度大大叔说出了自己的故事，他是个逃犯。
我们说这是印度大叔做出的一个改变啊，他坦开始面对自己的过去了。因为他逃到美国躲起来，就是因为他不想面对自己的过去啊，印度大叔也开始转改变了。其实就是所有人都是开始改变了啊。而且为什么单拎出来呢？这个后面是有伏笔。因为这个印度大大叔最后是解决了问题的啊。我们说这部戏里面主角不够主动。
所以说在故事大高潮解决问题是印度大叔啊。
那个33拍啊33拍。
然后社局终于等到了这个女主啊，两个人进展的感情进展比较顺利呃，约定了晚餐。
然后第34拍呃，大家配合他在这个机场露台上制造了一个浪漫的晚餐啊，这场戏是非常有意思的。而且两个人谈露心声，谈露心声讲什么呢？讲了这个片子的主题。
关于wait。
是吧。
而且呃两个人还这个亲嘴了啊，亲嘴了，看一下这场戏吧。
啊，不是看亲嘴啊，是看这个wa这个主题。我们说这个主题。
点题了，在这场戏里面。
我的 was in that。
But the Romanians themselves don't really give a shit.
你死了也思。
I'm 39 years old.
'sI told everybody I'm 33 the man I've date think I'm 27.
39.
I was 39 once.
I was 18 years old when I started working for the airlines, I've been doing this over 20 years and now there's no more pretending.
对。
Why my address book is alphabetical by city and my pager will always go off during dinner.
收取off求。
我想给。
I forI waiting for years.
时时刻刻准备着是吧？
这个女人代表的就是weing。
I been waiting for my whole life啊。
对，根本不知道在等什么。
所以其实你可以理解这个女孩啊，她就是代表。
嗯，你也可以理解为什么这段感情最终也没有长了啊。
我第一次看的时候其实还是蛮遗憾的。
还是希望这段感情成的啊，但实际上他注定成不了。首先是东西方，本来就是东西方啊，这两个人的比喻就是东西方，本来就是敬而远之啊。
我我 what do you do?
More than anything, I'm sure with that back there.
可以。
好，两个人把等待扔掉了啊，把等待扔掉了，约定13天之后见面。然后来到第35拍90分钟啊，这个男主开始做喷泉啊，做一个呃想要搞点浪漫啊，其实也是一个伏笔，36拍91分钟，南美小哥求婚成功啊，当然是在我们这个男主的帮助下啊，有些生终成眷属。
另外呢在这个位置，我们说这个位置一般是。
嗯嗯伙伴要挂掉了是吧？记不记得第三部马上要结束了，在这个位置，伙伴要死掉的。
对吧。
但是他在这里呢伙伴求婚成功，伙伴成功了，那你就明白了啊，预示着主角呀主角的爱情是肯定是成不了了啊，替身的爱情成了。再加上咱们刚才分析的啊，这个女主第一，她代表美国拜金嘛，喜欢钱，再加上呃她又是等待的那个代名词啊，我们。
主角最后是放弃了等待，拥抱了改变是吧？然后呢预示着我们主角这个爱情必闭挂啊，那是来到第三0棋牌就挂了啊。当然了，在反派的助力下，我们说主角虽然明着跟这个女的成不了，我们创作的时候知道也不打算让他成，但是还是要在反派的攻击下嘛。
是吧然后我们反派就向这个女主下手啊揭露男主的秘密，攻击这个男主的唯一软肋啊，就是他这个秘密。我们说他上来就有这个困境，就一直攻击这个同一个困境啊。然后女主斥责男主是骗子，因为他厌倦了wait啊，他本来以为男主可以让他不不等待了，谁知道还是一场等待。
还是一个骗子。好，第三幕结束，故事来到第四幕。
我们说第一幕的主题是被困，实际上就是激励上路啊。第二幕的主题是等待，因为原地等待是东方人的思维。第三幕的主题呢是呃做出改变。因为来到美国了，你还是要用灵活的手段去对付美国人，需要改变，包括对付那个呃管理者，对付那个美国妞啊。
B所以第三目的主题是改变。第四目的主题是什么？
同学们有没有记不记得我给大家曾经讲过某一个片子，它的两个目标也是一个dlay嘛。
两难型的就是说我既可以等待，也可以改变，等待改变，等待改变，不断的博弈。那第四目最终的解决方案是什么？
用一句话说就贼俗贼简单，就是等待那些值得等待的。
改变那些需要改变。
等待那些值得坚守的啊，改变那些必须要改变的。
我们说他这种故事他往往是这样，第二幕是等待。
主题第三幕是改变主题。那第四幕就是等待那些值得等待的，改变那些必须要改变的。所以来到第四幕这个故事就。
非常的完整，非常漂亮啊。38拍来到9797分钟。我们的的男主啊。
我们的男主用喷泉和罐子里的秘密打动了女主力挽狂澜啊。另外两个人等待的话题再次聊啊，坠入爱河呃，39块。
102分钟，第二天醒来啊，一切都解决了嘛，这个爱情也解决了。然后那个战争也结束了啊，庆祝呃，战争结束了，他可以回家了，甚至女主送来的通行证送来的通行证，也就是说。
通行证送来了啊，但是爱情失去了，两个人分手了。
这里大家再次思考一下这个爱情是不是。
呃，在这里失去，如果你写的话，你会怎么样啊？实际上因为这个女孩代表的是美国价值观，所以美国人是不会改变的啊。她在这里其实是想写。
呃，美国人是不会改变的。
第五40part。
100呃06分钟啊，他想去纽约，但是需要再次面对反派。
我们反派呢再次阻挠他，要遣送他回国。
并且用伙伴的安危威胁他。
就是他的那些伙伴啊威胁他。
妥协回国了。
我们说在故事的在。
这个最后阶段再次来一个小危机啊，他必须要回国了。实际他实现自己的目标就回国了。但是他现在实际呃想去纽约一趟嘛。
我们说在这里啊反派。
在这里啊大家可以理解为什么我说这个反派代表的就是美国，因为两个这个主角和对手代表的是东西方嘛，反派是美国嘛。
很客观。
很客观，因为他知道在机场打工的那些人，很多都是非法的。
但是他一直睁一只眼闭一只眼，只要你不违法。
我们说这其实就是美国的一个客观现实啊，美国的各类移民确实是这样，你如果不违法，他也不查你身份证啊，也不遣返你。咱们没有这个资格评说啊，因为咱们没到那个高度，但这个这个反派确实代表美国精神啊，人家美国人拍的电影反反派是美国人，这个还是比较那个。
相对来说还是有点大度的啊。
来到第41拍。
第111分钟。
印度大叔啊力挽狂澜，舍命拦飞机，造成航班延误。
大叔做出改变，而且在大叔做出改变，他明确的喊出了主题，他要干什么？
111分钟。
大叔也做出了改变，他要回家，他要面对他年轻时候犯下的错误。
还要改变。
故事来到第42排，113分钟，男主终于走出了机场，非常有仪式感的一场戏啊，大家自己去看一下，这也是名场面。男主踏出机场，这种当然是名场面，而且又到快要结束了。所以他。
非常有仪式感的一场戏。当然了，这场戏也非常温情的让他跟女主再次擦肩而过啊。再次我们就欣赏一下擦肩而过这场戏吧啊，看一下呃这个泽大琼斯这个的神言啊神言。
在110多分钟啊。
东西方点头致意，擦肩而过啊。东西方。
发乎情止于理。
最近还挺气合啊，来下一场43分钟啊，43拍来到第118分钟啊呃来到了酒吧那个罐子的秘密嘛，获得最后一个签名，完成了这个父亲的愿望啊，节奏就完全放下来了。因为所有的目标都实现了啊，节奏完全放下来啊，节奏。
全放下来，然后呃获得最后一个签名嘛。我们这场戏其实毫无悬念啊，肯定是一个温情的，伴随着萨ax斯风的一场很温情很舒缓的一场戏。然后这么一场舒缓的气放下来，后后最后这个结局就必须得剪短了。因为为什么？因为其实故事早就讲完了，那最后回家这场戏第44盘120分钟。
回家这场戏非常的简短有力啊，我们可以也可以。
看一眼吧，因为非常简单。
我说这场戏就非常的干脆啊，不拖泥带水。因为前面一场戏节奏拖的比较慢啊，这个所以这个分布啊还是非常合理的啊。再次说一下这个故事啊，剧本啊能挑出毛病的地方实在是不多啊呃，即便是有一些节奏上的问题呃，它也是一呃因为这个片子的属性，它保了主题啊，保了整个的调性。
所以说呃也没有办法啊。
我们说这个故事的主题在于等待啊，等待和改变这两个主题。最后的结论是。
等待那些值得等待的，改变那些没办法，没有办法改变呃，改改变那些必须改变的。而且呢由于是一个标准的东西方隐喻，所以说其实是非常震撼的一个故事啊。我们说里面的等待有多少男主。
男主是不是在等待？
男主在等待。
他的许可等待回家是吧？等待爱情。
女主也在等呃，那个爱情也在等待那个女孩子，对吧？她等待啥？
等待他的那个男人，对吧？等待着他那个虚无的爱情，南美小哥也在等待。
反派在等待。
是吧印度大叔也在等待一个。
结果因为他年轻的时候的犯过的错。
没有什么好美化的，你确实犯错了，你犯罪了，你就应该回去接受审判。
对不对？
然后他的父亲也在等待他父亲嗯也由于喜欢呃乐队，对吧？追追星在等待最后一个签名。
等到了自己去世啊，也没等来。这个在这部故事里啊啊这个我们说呃可以学习的地方，我跟刚才讲的时候已经讲了很多了啊啊，但是再次强调一下这个反派的设定，同学们去学一下，好不好？这个反派的设定是跟主角同样命运的人，这种设定方式啊是非常好。
另外呢我们说这部戏啊嗯严重影射了东西方的关系啊，嗯这个不完美的爱情其实也代表了东西方啊，擦出过火花，但是不可能成为眷终成眷属啊。因为我们这个呃我们说东方文化的这些在这部片子里面体现啊。
有听命令是吧？君臣父子纲肠嘛？他去美国就是为了完成父亲的遗愿，这是非常东方的思维方式。因为君臣父子纲肠。
在西方价值观里，父亲和儿子是好朋友，明白吗？在我们这里父父爱如山。
君臣父子钢厂啊，他会听父亲的命令，包括听管理者的命令，管理者不让他出去，他竟然真的就不出去了，不看着他他也不出去是吧？听命令，死脑筋。
但是呢很热爱劳动。
劳动致富呀呃适应环境能力强呀，这个东方人他他在那能找到钱，能在那生存下去，能在那找到床。
善于在夹缝里面生存啊，然后骨子里面的这种忠诚啊非常忠诚。
这是你看他在东方人的这些表达。
然后西方人呢？
西方人呢？
那个反派，再加上那个呃空姐两个人代表西方人，他们有什么特点？自大？
拜金对吧？强权制定规则。
但是有没有好一的有没有好的呢？一定程度上他们认为自己。
在照顾这个世界，因为他强大嘛。
他们自认为啊他们一定程度上在这部片子里面至少表现出来，他们认为自己在包容这个世界。
而且很有意思的是，在这部电影里面。
代表美方的。
两个黑人角色。
一个是那个保安，另外一是那个地勤美女。
都是非常正面的。
就这个还是不敢碰，你知道吧？代表东方或者是代表第三世界。其实在这个故事里面，他其实讲了并东西方是一方面，其实还是还有第三世界啊，我们说都谁代表的第三世界，有男主，对不对？男主，然后呢，还有南美小哥啊。
南美小哥。
然后这个呃印度大叔是吧？东欧出租车司机还有中中国头渡客啊，这些都是代表第三世纪的一些符号啊，一个标准的封闭环境的故事啊。里面呢严格来说并没有什么坏人，只是各自利益的人啊。嗯另外这部片子还有一个值得我们学的地方，就是刻画爱情或者刻画一些。
呃，有逼格的东西的时候啊，引经据典，有时候也挺有用的啊，引经据典。回到我们这堂课，我们最重要的东西，我们学习。当然，这种困境主题困在这种困在一个地方的片子，实际上我们看过不少了。但是这部片子我更想让大家学习如何用真实事件改编电影。
也就是说，你拿到一个真实事件的时候，你都要从哪些地方下手。这部片子的结构很简单。我刚才已经讲完了，先是一个困境，把它困在这儿。然后第一阶段主题是等待，第二阶段的主题是改变。第三阶段的主题是等待那些该等待的，坚持那些该坚持的，但是也改变那些改需要改变的，抛弃那些需要抛弃的。
对不对？
四部分相当简单。
那这部电影我们我让你们看，最主要的是让你们学真实事件，改变电影，哪些事情是可以改的，哪些事情是是保留。
这部电影我们说有至少我们有5个地方是改变的。
至少有5个电替方去改变。第一，这个爱情一定是加出来的。
对不对？
我们说这个电影是一个真实事件，当时确实有一个小国家的人飞到那个那个纽约机场，然后被困在那儿了。
这是个真实事件，非常有戏剧冲突，确实非常好看。而且这个人经常在竟然在机场生活了好几个月，对吧？我们说这个故事这个新闻当然值得写成电影，但是你怎么改呢？第一上来就加爱情。
他在机场，那加克跟空姐的爱情吗？好也好看，也好听，也好宣传呀。
是不是这爱情一定是假持出来的。你想想看，一个从穷的国家来的四十几岁的大叔也没什么钱。这个这个呃我跟你说，住在机场，我跟你说，这卫生条件也不可能太好，他即便能在那住下。
他还能泡空姐儿。
所以说这个爱情一定是嫁出来的。
第二。
由于这个故事本身比较被动，所以必须增加角色，增加支线。
这个也是肯定增加的对吧？那些伙伴，印度人、墨西哥小哥增加了。
第三。
反派增强烈度，对吧？那个反派多次诱惑他出轨，然后摁在那欺负他，然后那个解决大危机。我们说这些烈度肯定是增加出来的。第四，不能光往狠里增加，不能光增加烈度，增加丑肉面一定程度还是要美化，对吧？把这个故事拍的很美。整个机场的人对他很友善。
为他开party称他为goat，为他欢呼，请他喝啤酒，这些肯定是美化的。第五点也是最重要的最后的一点。
高社会意义。我们说这个故事当时发生的时候，战乱国的人到美国旅游，然后被困在那儿了。
他都未必真的是去收集父亲的尖名。
对吧但是呢创作者敏锐的捕捉到了东方的小国战争，对吧？无家可归来到美国东西方文化八高。
我们说这就是创作者硬拔的，绝对是硬巴的。人家这个人只是经历了一个倒霉事儿，跟东西方没关系，把它做成了一个。我们说机场，你相当于是一个缓冲区，是一个国际中转区嘛，它是东西方碰撞的一个阵地。你你看整个比喻就非常好了。
啊，这个故事一看，我跟你说，创作者当时看到这个素材，想到这个改编方式绝对是非常兴奋的，太美好了这个结构。
东方西方展。
我们美国是有规矩的，我们包容他还是欺负他啊，这个对撞哎，我跟你说创作者发现这种素材，然后想到我可以套这么一个结构，它是相当兴奋的。
这个故事在设计之初就已经赢了，实际上明白吧？
还是非常好的啊非常好的。至于有同学说，保安队长众目睽睽把他放走这个事情，我刚才也解释过了啊，确实第一需要政治正确啊，需要政治正确的。因为那是个黑人啊。
增加这么一个小小的火彩蛋啊，当然了，没有这场戏，他就是在群众的护送下逃出去了。然后那个官方没追上，其实也是可以的。好吧，这场戏确实啊如果是那个呃那个反派带着保安队长来撵，但是呢群众们群策群力。
那些机场的各着劳动人民把他俩把他放走了，呃，也可以。
但是因为美国的环境啊，你把黑人塑造的有人情味儿，实际上是可以获得很多的社会好感的，包括德奖呀，包括那个票房呀，明白吗？咱们要理解一下他们有这个国情啊。好，这个故事啊，我再次跟大家强调一下这个。
确实是非常值得我们学习啊非常值得我们学习。没有我们不谈政治啊，我们不谈政治呃，只说啊。
艺术创作。
片子还是很好的啊。
斯皮尔伯格啊大师作品，再加上配上这种汤姆汉克斯这种级别的啊影帝啊，整个片子执行的非常好。
我希望大家。
好好记笔记。
研究一下你手里的那个所谓的真实新闻素材。那这节课就先到这儿，咱们。
下节课再见啊，拜拜各位。
。